hey everybody welcome back to another
extremely delayed episode of planet
coaster this one was supposed to come
out a few weeks ago but then I got sick
I still kind of am so I'm gonna try to
edit out the cuffs then some stuff
happened and basically eventually the
whole commentary became sort of outdated
because we're still talking about the
update as if it were something that was
yet to come
which obviously now it isn't so here I
am recording this and hopefully this one
is going to be a little bit better than
the original one in any case what I'll
be working on in this episode is you
know generally as we're going to the end
of this project just a bunch of smaller
things and trying to finish up all kinds
of stuff that I kind of left unfinished
earlier but the real needs of the
episode for now I think is the small
observation tower that I decided to
build on this part of the park now
basically it's kind of you know what I'm
gonna say it's kind of a weenie sort of
it's very small it's not really a major
weenie it's it's a really minor sort of
soap weenie if you were to speak it I
found it that way
but it's something that I wanted to put
in here because without it this whole
corner of the park would just kind of be
dead and really have no thing to really
focus on and wow it would be fine to
just kind of have a few trees over here
and finish up the park and leave enough
space for that whole backstage area
which would supposedly be behind all of
this it's not really as interesting as
having something at least to have a bit
of a landmark in this part of the
landscape so the only thing I could
really come up with was something that
you see sometimes if you walk around in
the forest at least I've done quite a
bit of walking around in the forests in
the Alps because that's always what we
would do in summer vacations with my
family so you'd often find all of these
little wooden huts or little observation
towers or whatever really sometimes for
people just who want to stay over nights
in one of these small huts as they're
hiking in the mountains sometimes it's
for the people who actually need to care
for the whole area all the specifics of
everything I don't really know but
sometimes you'll see these little huts
or wouldn't I
and that's something that I thought
would be interesting to add into Jaeger
horn as well and it would be a sort of
building that's good for a very small
little point of interest somewhere in
the park but not really a major thing so
we're gonna keep it quite simple really
the focus here is to do as much as I can
with as little pieces as I can and
experiment a little bit with some of the
pieces so in this case I'm not actually
using the standard wooden planks that
you see me use a lot or that people have
been using pretty much as the go-to
wooden planks I wanted to use the rails
actually or the the wooden planks that
are supposedly for the bottoms of the
rails as wooden planks in this case
because I think their textures a little
bit more interesting you can't recolor
them but they have a little bit more of
a rustic texture to them and it just
kind of fits the build of this building
a little bit more it's supposed to be
this kind of thing which you don't
really care after too much so everything
is kind of weathered in a way so yeah
it's just a simple structure and with a
small ladder and something to keep the
basic structural integrity of the tower
intact and on top of that just a small
observation platform with a small spire
which I'll be making myself speaking of
which something at which at this point
in the original recording I started
talking about is the new theme makers
tool kits that was the name I keep sort
of mixing it up because it's a little
bit of a tongue twister but yeah the tea
makers toolkit is something that's gonna
be added into planet coaster eventually
so far it's not really been revealed
when exactly this is gonna come out and
I think by the time I released this
video it still won't be but it's
sometime this year and this year isn't
going on for too long anymore so it's
sometime soon and for those who aren't
too informed about this basically the
theme makers toolkit is an addition to
planet coaster it's a little bit of its
own kind of program through which people
are going to be able to upload their own
3d models into the game and well this is
obviously a really huge thing for a
planet coaster it's something that I've
been wishing for since basically the
beginning of
all of this and I've been wondering
about ever since planet coaster got
announced because back in the roller
coaster in three days custom content is
more or less what made the game
obviously there was lots of good stuff
in the original game as well but custom
content is how it managed to kind of
keep the community going for over ten
years after the game came out now I
don't know if planet coaster is gonna be
alive on that sort of timeframe it
probably will have some kind of
community if no planet coaster to is
gonna come out which we don't know much
about either but it's something which I
just really wanted to have at some point
because eventually you kind of tend to
run out of things that you can do with
the given pieces in the game and even
though planet coaster is lots of
different pieces and we keep getting new
DLCs and as you go on there's so many
different combinations that you can make
with the existing pieces it's never
quite the same as being able to really
literally add your own 3d models into
the game so it's an update which I'm
really curious about something which
you've been looking forward to for such
a long time and something which is gonna
make a lot of parts of the game much
easier really so for a Jaeger horn for
instance I've made almost all of the
roofs completely myself out of all kinds
of small pieces and while there is a
sort of fun experience to that it's also
something that just kind of tends to
ruin the experience of the game itself
because by now Jaeger horn is lagging a
lot more than it should because all of
the roofs are made up of thousands of
different pieces and I can't even make
the blueprints out of the station
building because it's something like
15,000 pieces or something like that in
total which is just gonna you know have
to fit in four different blueprints so
that doesn't really work out so yeah I'm
really looking forward to this and hell
I might even see if I can dabble a
little bit in some 3d modelling I used
to make custom content in roller-coaster
country back in the days but me being
the newb that I am I always used
Sketchup and I never bothered to learn
another
gram but for planet coaster it's gonna
be limited to Maya and probably I think
on a desk and also blender but with all
of these things I basically have zero
experience so we'll see how that goes
eventually anyway to kind of catch up on
the video a little bit more again
basically at this point I'm finishing up
the foliage in the way that I was
intending to from the beginning so
nothing really too spectacular going on
here I didn't want to do too much with
EQ either I'm just trying to add a few
things on the ground
that would kind of fits with the rest of
the park but I didn't want to make it a
very themed experience because the whole
idea of the cue I think is mostly to
kind of get you going through the
landscape of the coaster look at the
coaster and the entire scenery then it
goes through so it's not really meant
for the queue itself to be sort of the
highlights of the experience it's just
sort of giving people the space to look
at their surroundings so that's why I
didn't want to put a lot of trees around
the queue or obstruct the view of the
rest of the coaster I just want to keep
it as simple is and open as possible so
you kind of have that coaster and queue
interaction it's a little bit actually
it's very much like the queues of Baron
1898 and symbolic in the efteling I
don't know if I really named drop this
yet but you can tell that the small
buildings that I put over the queue with
their roofs are very much like the
buildings that are put over the symbolic
akyuu and the very sort of meandering
queue that goes through the landscape of
the coaster and the way that all of the
bushes and shrubs and everything is
built around that it's very much Baron
1898 like so that's where a lot of the
inspiration for that came from now back
to a completely different part of the
park this is my last little bits of sort
of unfinished coaster so there's still a
catwalk missing over here and some of
the scenery around here so I figure it
would be right about time to kind of fix
that and finally finish this
I'm not really going to do anything with
that suspension bridge that's just kind
of there as a hedge hopper because for
some reason the the prospects of getting
your head chopped off is something
that's really enjoyable on
rollercoasters I still don't really get
it but that's the thing I feel that way
too so it's always nice to add something
which almost chops off the head of your
people so decided to kind of spice up
the area with that but aside from that
there is nothing really going on here
just trying to finish up the rockwork
finish up all of the catwalks and the
foliage and it's another example of
stuff that I wish I could import into
the game itself because when it comes to
these catwalks for instance it's the
kind of thing which looks alright like
you don't absolutely need to be able to
get 3d models imported into the game to
make this sort of thing you can pretty
much do it the way that I've been doing
it so far so there's not really a
problem there but these things are all
made out of fountains and that's
definitely also one of those problems
that kind of wrecks up as I'm building
here because even though this all looks
fine on the ground and it's just a kind
of simple nice catwalk texture on the
side of the track underneath the ground
and in the parts of the park which you
don't see because it's Underground
there's hundreds of little fountains
throwing out their textures and their
particle effects and all those
animations going on so that's that is
something which contributes to the leg
of the park and while it's not even too
bad it's just a sort of thing where I
imagine a programmer or anybody who
really works on games kind of cringes at
the thought of all of these things being
hundreds of fountains and not just being
an entire waste of processing power hell
maybe it's even environmentally bad to
build this kind of way I mean in a way
you're using more computing processing
power than you necessarily need to so I
don't know if it can be said that this
new update is gonna fight climate change
I'm not too knowledgeable about
computers about that but maybe it does I
don't know
in any case it is something that kind of
needs to be fixed because making
catwalks and fountains well nice and
while a nice challenge is something that
isn't really ideal and this is something
that was brought up in the reasons I
think schematics podcast yeah about the
see makers toolkit as well some people
are already arguing that it's part of
the fun of playing planet coaster is
taking all of these different pieces and
kind of figuring out what you can do
with it right so this is one of the
things that I sort of took with me as
baggage from rollercoaster country and
in which back in the days of like
grizzly Valley that was sort of a new
and up-and-coming way of playing the
game which ended up changing the game
completely and so some people are just
kind of arguing that you know maybe this
whole custom contents isn't really that
much of a great game changer in that
currently a lot of the fun of playing
planet coaster is taking all these
pieces of parts and being so creative in
building different things with them
almost like you're solving a puzzle in a
way and while I can kind of see that
sentiments I don't really think it
applies because in the end taking pieces
and using them for completely different
things is kind of something that I got
from roller coaster and three in the end
back in the first days of Planet poster
that was something completely new but
when roller coaster country was really a
thing that's something that people used
to do all the time even with custom
content because as much as it's great to
have custom content it takes a lot of
time and a lot of efforts to make even
just one piece so you are still somewhat
limited and getting all kinds of new
pieces from a community perspective just
kind of opens up the possibilities of
how creatively you use different pieces
so for instance I remember chimneys is
something that I was credited with as
kind of changing the game and planet
coaster because I used to use chimneys
for building all kinds of things that
they were not supposed to be for in the
first days of planet coaster but I
remember very fondly that chimneys from
rollercoaster country custom content
sets were always popping up everywhere
in all kinds of different uses
the shyguy alpine village chimneys
turned out to be some of the most
popular pillars and fence pieces and
stuff like that so really when you get
custom content I just I just think it
kind of opens up more avenues for
creativity rather than just completely
stifling it by giving you more pieces
anyway that's just my view in it and
that's why I am actually really looking
forward to seeing this in the game and
seeing how this is gonna work and how
you know the community is gonna interact
with this as well anyway back to planet
coaster and what I'm currently building
the final thing I wanted to do in this
episode is work on this little building
which is the very last part of the sort
of main facade of the park which I
didn't finish yet and it's one of those
things which I've been sort of
procrastinating on because the further
this park develops the further I kinda
like it but as a sort of side effects of
that the more I'm also afraid to keep
adding things to it I don't know if
anybody else kind of feels this way
sometimes but sometimes your stuff just
ends up sort of accidentally really good
and you like it but it's still kind of
unfinished and with everything you keep
adding you just kind of feel more and
more afraid that it's gonna ruin what
you have so far because it might not fit
in or it might just tie in you destroy
the the vibe of the area and that's what
I've kind of been feeling with Jaeger
horn more and more with everything that
I add it's less of a case of like does
this look good and more of a case of
like does it actually fit in with the
park so far or does it just completely
ruin it and for this building I really
couldn't figure out what I wanted to do
with it because I wanted to deviate a
little bit from the style of all the
other buildings in this whole row here
but I wasn't really sure how to do that
in a way that wouldn't deviate
ridiculously from the building so far
and just ruin the whole atmosphere so
what I wanted to go for is more of a
sort of town building obviously in the
Alps you'll get all of these different
houses in the rural areas and in small
villages which look a lot like the
buildings in the rest
of this whole row of facades but you
also have these more sort of inner city
buildings which you'll find in the
middle of salzburg or innsbruck or
places like that which have a very
different type of look and that's
something which I wanted to try it with
this building a little bit more it uses
less wood it's a little bit more
classical looking and just overall a
slightly different style and I guess in
the end this building actually works out
all right I put a little ice cream shop
in there but it's only kind of imaginary
because I didn't want to ruin the nice
look of the actual door with a star so
it's a little bit of a fake ice cream
shop here and uses some of the elements
which I believe if I remember correctly
are kind of typical for the area so for
instance some of the painted decorations
are coming back here
the building has some very classical
looking decorations on the walls but
rather than being actual stone
sculptures it's all just kind of painted
on the walls so for that I use the
Christmas decorations again to give some
sort of painted vibes to the decorations
and there's a lot less wood there's no
really wooden frameworks going on as
with the other buildings there's more of
a classical look to it so a very
traditional sort of shop fronts some
pillars on the sides a lot of stone
details and instead of a very large
gable on the front of the building the
only thing that I really added to this
to give it a sense of direction to give
it a sense of you know this part of the
building is the front is a small little
part over here he's taking out of the
roof as sort of a large dormer and a
decoration which kind of serves as the
same purpose of giving you the idea of
no this is the front of the building and
I'm not just looking at the back and of
course me being me I wanted to add a
very pointy bits to the top as well
because you know building doesn't really
work out that well without a unsewn peak
style kind of spire on top of it which
is actually interesting because I
couldn't show this in this video because
this is a very old video and is
recorded long before the newest update
came out but the newest update contains
a really interesting iron piece which
can be really great for these kind of
small spires so I'll be using that from
now on instead of the weird cables just
something fun I thought is added in this
new updates as one of those small pieces
which you can use in many ways which is
not really intended for in any case
that's it for this episode so thank you
guys for watching and I hope to see you
again next time
[Music]